check this out you guys have heard their
riots going on
we got the story from abc 5 eyewitness
news
sources say washington county attorney's
office expected to charge officer in
brooklyn center shooting on wednesday
so this is this woman her name is kim
potter the case was sent to the
washington county attorney's office to
avoid a conflict of interest with the
hennepin county attorney's office
which works closely with brooklyn
center's police on criminal cases
the extent of the charges will be
learned tomorrow brooklyn center police
released body camera
video that shows officer potter shooting
and killing 20 year old dante wright
sunday afternoon
brooklyn center's former police chief
tim gannon he police chief resigned
today this is nuts the city's
like the whole area is just falling
apart stadium believed potter
accidentally discharged her weapon
believing she was using her taser not
her gun potter and ganon resigned from
brooklyn center police department on
tuesday and you know what
i can't speak too much for this this
officer kim potter
she shot somebody cops look i don't care
who you are you're responsible for what
comes out of your gun
that's just basic you know gun
responsibility
i understand it wasn't intentional or at
least that's what they're claiming we'll
see how this investigation goes
but for the police chiefs to resign i'm
like i'm giving applauses
yeah bravo i think every single cop in
the in the twin cities area and suburbs
they should all right now turn in their
badges
and walk why they should all resign
all of them right now right at once you
must be joking
i am not i mean it why do you think they
should resign well because these
leftists have demanded the police be
abolished
i think the police say okay i think yes
absolutely
police you're not wanted here the
activists have said so the logic oozes
out
you know what the issue is where are the
regular people standing up
and saying no don't do this when the
police
were under threat last year when the
riots were sweeping across the
the state in these cities the police
were scapegoated were insulted berated
over over the actions of a few i'm not a
big fan of the place as a whole i think
they need reform
but i understand individuals many of
these cops they're good people they're
not trying to get in between and get in
politics
there are some real risks with trying to
neutrally enforce the law when you've
got some people saying yeah do one thing
some people saying
gotta do the other thing and then
accidents happen some cops are really
bad people they should be able to
accountable
but we need police we a civil society
requires police to be able to make
arrests
this guy dante right he was wanted now
they're reporting an aggravated robbery
so that was his warrant
like okay that's a legit crime don't
resist
if the cops are arresting you you fight
it in court and he decided to jump in
his car and and scuffle out with the
cops
these cops are being treated like trash
so i say
they show all of these people they they
they tell the people of
you know where they live if you won't if
people here won't stand up for us
if people here aren't willing to do what
it takes to empower the police to
protect them
they must not want them there so here's
what i see the loudest the squeaky wheel
are those who riot
saying abolish the police rashida to
labe what did she say no more policing
no more get him out of there and the
cops stand to fight and say we will not
stand for this
but i mean we've been seeing even
conservatives throw blue lives matter
flags in the dirt and step on
it because the cops were enforcing these
unconstitutional lockdowns
right now what we need are the regular
people to prove
that they actually want the police if
they won't do that
then as far as i'm concerned the vote's
in but how do they do that
stand up go outside protest hold big
rallies and say we support our police
they won't do it though they will not do
it says to me
they don't care i really really think
most people don't care about any of this
and so my point is what do you think
will happen if the police say
blue flu we're all sick it will take 10
seconds
for the people of these cities to call
the officers personally and say please i
beg of you come back or the department
will hire a bunch of scabs
and the crap officers will come in and
do really crappy jobs and be violent and
even worse
what do you think is happening already
is that all the good cops i should say
all of them but many of the good cops
quit
last year in seattle in portland and
minneapolis we saw across the country in
exodus
the good cops were the ones saying i
will not be abused
i will not be a party to this and i will
not stand by while the d.a the
prosecutors allow rioters to destroy
these cities and they do nothing when we
arrest them
i'm done you got it they voted for this
they had an election
and they voted for this so at this point
i'm dumbfounded as the police who think
they're going to be accept what they're
doing is acceptable in a community that
absolutely despises them
i i also think that we have to be
careful here though because i think the
very best cops
stay for all this in in the same way
that some of the very best
you know members of the military or
whatever professional branch under
pressure nurses
um you know that they a sense of duty
which is kind of antithetical to
to some of the contemporary you know
discourse but but
people who truly believe that the
kinship of service
uh of going out there and still doing it
um
whether for religious reasons just moral
reasons um
you know i i i agree that at the
political level i agree with you
i'm surprised that frankly the
republican party hasn't been more
aggressive in
terms of saying hey look body cameras
zero some game
let's get those body cameras everyone
right it's great good cops
love it great evidence okay what's the
worst that happens they get you know
locker room talk is caught in the car
yeah but most of us in society think of
this okay fine
um but but at the level of
you know again receded sleep right who
is held up
as uh by the media will say on one hand
well she doesn't represent the
democratic party on the other hand this
great sort of new visionary for the
party
you know having the cake and eating it
yeah you know this is pretty
wacko stuff the big issue is that
these cops will arrest these extremists
the rioters the looters and then the da
will say
you're free to go and release them
without charge a bunch of felony charges
in portland got dropped
and these cops are like well i'll just
keep doing the same thing and expect a
different outcome or i guess some of the
cops are probably like well i know
they're not going to jail but i sure
love bashing skulls
i can't i can't imagine so let me let me
slow down for a minute
state police who were brought in to
portland retreated
saying we arrest these people and the
prosecutors let them go
we're done we're not doing this anymore
and i'm like thank you
that makes sense and then what happened
was the dhs
deputized state police as federal
law enforcement so that when the state
police arrested someone the federal
prosecutors could step in
brilliant no escalation of force no
military coming in and now these people
were getting prosecuted and you knew
what happened many of the activists ran
scared
i shouldn't i shouldn't call them
activists activists are great these are
extremists and terrorists they started
panicking writing blogs saying
the fbi showed up to my house the fbi
showed to my friend's house
this is not a game anymore the cost
for the extremists when they burn down
buildings is much
too low they're risking people's lives
there was active gunfire the other night
in in the minneapolis area
and the cost for these people is zero in
portland what happened to those guys who
fired hundreds of rounds
from rifles into an suv with two
teenagers killing them
the cost was nothing and these
extremists know it
they can go out they can burn things
down and nothing will happen well the
cost is
cop will jam you up but don't worry your
good buddy and the da will cut you loose
in two seconds and the cops will just
shrug
the cops need to be like i'm not gonna
do it you do it
i also think one of the great tragic you
know
ironies here is that you know the black
lives matter movement
um you know trying to address you know
real issues
at the same time the utter unwillingness
to face up to the fact that we talk
about what do police officers do for
example
we've seen it right in the in the summer
crime waves baltimore uh chicago
it was a baltimore sun columnist who
wrote a great piece on this i think you
know
a year ago the cops stop
doing their job right that they that i
am not going to entertain this personal
risk to me this liability
vilification in case i get it wrong and
what is the consequence of that well
in some of these areas in many of these
cities where the predominant
homicide issue is young black men
killing other young black men
more young black men die and and and as
a society
then when we have rasheeda sleep saying
this does she seriously care about
the intro she's talking about the facts
would suggest i would say forensically
that she does not uh and and making that
case
you know you would think there would be
opportunities here for for
you know young republican mayors
independent
mayors to run and say hey we are going
to have accountability on the part of
the police again that body camera issue
um you know very well-funded uh internal
affairs departments but at the same time
we're going to go out and try and stop
criminality
and there's a racism in the sense that
people wouldn't want that you know of
course
most people want to be able to live
their lives in safety
you take a look at what the left tends
to care about what the media tends to
report on
and it's getting just so obvious it's
mind-numbing
you know there was there's a viral tweet
i can't remember where it's from so
forgive me but they were saying
something like the media actually
you know sorts through all the different
news stories
trying to find the one story that would
cause the most hate and division
that will get them traffic and get them
clicks to their website and that fuels
all of this
then you end up with a bunch of young
people who are deranged i mean there's a
video
i don't know if you guys have seen it
where it's this guy with no shirt on on
the ground just screaming and
crying that glove's better like
at the top of his lungs and i'm like
this man needs to turn twitter off
turn off the tv like go see a movie go
go watch burns of birds of prey
maybe he'll like that one okay and then
he'll just like calm down
dude the world is not ending things are
not worse than they've ever been these
people have genuinely gone nuts
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you